[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
buongiorno comici st comi ci sta come
dice questo vocabolario è un neologismo
che ho inventato per alto definirmi allo
stato attuale la grammatica italiana
questa parola così dare una parola
macedonia o con un altro termine
veramente brutto neologismo sincronico
che altro non è che unire due parole già
esistenti che hanno già un significato
per farmi una nuova infatti con ci sta e
l'unione delle parole comico e ciclista
il primo spettacolo della mia vita l'ho
fatto che avevo da poco compiuto 5 anni
ed è stata la recita di natale all'asilo
dove la mia missione era quello di
farete suo bambino ha solo cristina che
era la regista deciso carbonio e propria
fatta anzi
pesantissima ma questa è l'altra storia
da allora sono passati 35 anni e questo
lungo tempo non posso che considerare la
persona fortunata ha avuto il privilegio
di poter né esibire su ogni tipo di
palco con ogni tipo di spettacolo non
solo in italia ma anche in vari parti
del mondo
all'età di 35 anni invece è scattato il
colpo di fulmine colpo di fulmine per la
bicicletta è vero anche che sono nato e
cresciuto a ferrara quindi diciamo che
il dna della bicicletta probabilmente
già nel giro dentro ma sono passato da
una normale city bike aa1 performante
seppur non avevo alcuna idea di fare
gare competizione cose del genere
proprio solo per il gusto di pedalare e
poi ha scoperto anche che è stato per il
gusto di cambiare prospettiva perché lo
ammetto e oggi sono qua a fare da outing
fino a non molto tempo fa era uno di
quelli che vedere i ciclisti per strada
provo un certo senso di irritazione non
nascondo che molte volte il nostro non
basato da dietro mandando degli insulti
adesso mi sono trovato dall'altro lato
quindi sto riprendendo i dietro tutti
gli insulti anche con gli interessi e mi
sono reso conto che il karma è veramente
fighissimo la cosa che la storia che vi
racconto oggi la storia mia inizia a
fine novembre del 2016 quando
invitato a fare degli interventi comici
all'interno del cala di previsione di un
importante circuito nazionale indica
mary mountain bike e di vengo a
conoscenza di una gara bizzarra la gara
a tappe più alte del mondo
l'animalier maya si smonta bike race è
una gara che si corre in india al nord
dell'india nella piccola regione
dell'andata che si trova nel kashmir che
confina da una parte con il tibet che si
trova esattamente dall'altro lato della
rete di variante dall'altra c'è il
pakistan con la catena del karakorum una
zona particolare fantastica e una gara
incredibile una gara di setup e di quali
600 chilometri con 9.000 metri di
dislivello
ogni tappa prevede lo scavalcare una
cima di oltre 5000 metri fino ad
arrivare alla luce della cronoscalata
l'ultima tappa del passo carrozzabile
più alto al mondo che si chiama card un
pin up as a 5.600 due metri
impossibile stata la prima cosa che ho
pensato impossibile una roba da folli
chi è che voglia di fare una roba del
genere in quel periodo avevo da poco
finito di registrare una trasmissione
non avevo particolari progetti per la
testa
mi limito a rispondere alle telefonate
che mi arrivavano per propormi serate
cose del genere
diciamo che ero entrato nella solita
routine so che molti
penseranno nel toro morro reatino in un
qualche modo anche nel mio lavoro c'è
una certa un team e io devo ammettere
che questo non sicuramente un mio limite
la routine mi logora totalmente e quindi
cerchiamo sempre di riempire i vuoti che
mi dava la routine prendendo sempre più
vivendi andando a destra e sinistra
quindi entriamo nella routine della
routine per una volta nella mia vita
invece ho deciso di fermarmi e da
satellitare ed è stata quella volta che
è derivata ispirazione quali fanno
pensare ma sarà così impossibile fare
questa gara che era la terza edizione
quindi vuol dire che se le due i disegni
precedenti le hanno portate termine e
non si calcolavano dei decessi
evidentemente si può fare questa è stata
la scintilla incredibile che mi ha fatto
scattare una roba stranissima che è
partita dalla pancia ed è proprio capire
che quella che considerava il filo a
poco
una follia poteva diventare una
fantastica opportunità
e chiaro che quello che vi sto
raccontando oggi non è realtà non è
altro che parlare col senno di poi
ripercorrere una strada che conosco
perfettamente ma ho avuto tempo più di
un anno per riuscire a pensare a quello
che è successo perché mi sono reso conto
che appena materiali l'obiettivo non c'è
motivo per cui pensare che tu non riesca
ad arrivare alla fine de gaulle
obiettivo è vero che ci sono delle
difficoltà bisogna sempre affrontare
degli ostacoli che ti possono mettere a
dura prova e che molte volte mi fanno
dire ma anche meno farmaci 40 ma no dai
adesso un altro lavoro è stata quella la
scintilla che mi ha fatto capire una
cosa fantastica che siamo noi e solo noi
a scegliere chi e che cosa vogliamo
essere in ogni istante della nostra vita
perché troppo spesso si tende a lasciar
segnare all'omologazione a persistere in
doveri dovuti a scelte che abbiamo fatto
e per noi invece realtà sono scelte che
vengono fatte per un quieto vivere per
un contesto sociale per volte si fa la
scelta per dire no vabbè ma ormai ho
questo rapporto con questo lavoro mi
dispiace potrei ferire la mia compagna
potrà inserire i miei genitori poter
inserire i miei amici sono se questa
cosa quindi per non ferire con gli altri
noi stessi ed è stato questo un momento
che mi ha aspettato molto ovvio che ho
avuto dei grandi tutti per di tubi che
mi hanno sempre quarant'anni che il mio
unico sport che ho fatto da ragazzino
giocato a calcio poi ho smesso però se
posso capire un mondiale di sollevamento
birra questi ronnie scott per me lo
sport iraq guardando la tv mio 40 anni
faccio mai affrontare una gara del
genere potrò mai di fare il ciclista
potrò mai trasformati qualcosa di simile
ad un atleta per una nota della mia vita
abbandonato qualsiasi aspettativa in
qualsiasi presunzione e qualsiasi paura
e non ho fatto nient'altro che affidarmi
a quello che mi diceva alla mia pancia
perché ogni volta che mi veniva
l'istinto di fare qualcosa
ho pensato che fosse la cosa giusta ed è
così che si è creata automaticamente una
tabella di marcia che si è formata e
trasformata più e più volte nel fratello
perché io avevo ben chiaro un obiettivo
io mi ero già visto ma proprio mi ero
visto io ero visto attraversare il
traguardo di questa gara sebbene non
sapessi assolutamente come fossero fatti
quei posti non sapevo assolutamente come
si potesse affrontare una gara ma mi ero
visto tagliare il traguardo
e quando si fa un puzzle credo che qua
nella maggior parte abbia fatto un paso
nella vita è un puzzle
le immagini che c'è sulla scatola è il
nostro obiettivo finale e non c'è nessun
dubbio e ce la faremo a fare questi male
imperdibile quella è ci si può mettere
più dentro meno tempo ma quella è la
cosa che non sappiamo e imperfetti mi
come vanno messi ma una certezza ce
l'abbiamo
i pezzetti di solamente perché quella
scatola e in questo caso quella scatola
non erano altro che io e dobbiamo solo
cercare di capire questi pezzettini come
poterli mettere insieme ed è così che
hanno il mio countdown perché mi sono
ritrovato a fine dicembre del 2016 a
scegliere di fare una gara che si
sarebbe corsa ad una del 2017 e nel
lasso di tempo limiti ma alla rinfusa
non sapevo esattamente da che parte
parare se quindi il mister sa quello che
mi viene faccio e ho cominciato a
riprendermi a riprendere il perché ho
pensato bello documentare tutto ciò
magari film ho iniziato a scrivere sul
mio blog ho pensato a delle cose che
potevano essere realmente necessario
tivoli ha ceduto la bicicletta e quindi
che l'ho fatto ho contattato
un'importante casa di produzione di
mountain bike sono andato a spiegare
questa idea fumosa che verona
evidentemente sullo stato molto
convincente perché al primo appuntamento
ottenuto la bicicletta e quando sono
usciti da lì ha detto subito che fare
veramente sta gara
visto che mi considerava un ignorante in
materia ho detto come ci si fa ad
allenare avrò bisogno di un relatore ha
trovato l'allenatore sul suo
suggerimento
poi mi sono avvalso anche della
collaborazione di una nutrizionista
perché lì si trattava di fare tanti
cambi cambiare dal passare a dall'uscire
una volta settimana per svago oppure
anche la ruota di due settimane a dover
stare in sella per sei sette giorni a
settimana macinando chilometri pedalando
tutti i giorni con alle reti sempre più
lunghi sempre più duri che questa cosa
ma applicava non solo un cambio di
abitudini di orari e di impegni ma con
cambia livello dell'alimentazione mia
vita da sorta di illuminazione voglio
dare un nome al progetto e mi progetto
di lato nome l'ho chiamato dai ho
scoperto che è stata veramente una
filiazione ho avuto una bella dai perché
perché è proprio esortativo io mi vedevo
io in bicicletta con gianni morandi di
fianco che mi diceva dai avevamo questa
scena no dai è stata anche una cosa
fantastica perché ogni volta che
raccontavo a delle persone sai che sto
preparando una gara per andare
sull'himalaya e mi rispondevano sempre
inoltre dai ho scoperto essere un
fantastico anonimo
le tre lettere che compongono dai sono
le riffe anni della frase dove arrivo io
alla quale voluto d'annata con la
sfumatura dove arrivo io vi posso
assicurare che ci potete arrivare anche
voi che non sono super eroe
assolutamente mettere andava avanti il
tutto mi sono reso conto di questo
giochino diventava sempre più gonfio più
grosso e più costoso ho fatto un po di
calcoli e mi sono reso conto di una cosa
che avrei dovuto sostenere dei costi che
purtroppo non potevo permettermi ma per
per messo in difficoltà quindi di
conseguenza che cosa ho fatto
c'è voluta fare una rapina alle poste
ma cercate response ho ricevuto un
mucchio di rifiuti tantissimi ma non so
come o continuavo a conservare una certa
serenità perché sapevo benissimo che
quel tassello del puzzle c'era l'inter
pesca scatola non lo vedevo io fin
quando ad un certo giorno oggi ha detto
calcolo ed è arrivato allo sforzo
ho pensato anche sarà una lunga e dura
preparazione
dovrò affrontare anche una gara delle
quote che io fuori da un aereo non ho
mai visto 5000 metri come si sta mag e
resa a seguire dall'equipe medica e così
da un giorno all'altro mi sono trovato a
fare tanti di quei test che mi sembrava
di essere ivan drago in rocky e infine
un altro ultimo incontro che è stato
fantastico fondamentale con la psicologa
dello sport siamo visti sono cinque
volte la mia tattica innocenti veramente
importanti ai fondali in fabbrica
praticamente un team è un progetto senza
rendermene conto
ho creato ed un progetto un team
composto da persone che erano molto più
bravi competenti divenne il loro canto
specifico io non ho dovuto fare
nient'altro che ascoltare imparare e
mettere insieme tutti i perfettini di
questo puzzle in modo che l'immagine che
era presente sulla mia scatola si
potesse materializzare
questo è il punto più alto in cui sono
stato nella mia vita fuori da un aereo
sono 5.602 metri per l'esattezza 5603
cadute saldo e a questa gara alla fine
abbiamo partecipato solo in 15 anche
perché in essi sono tanti peones che
abbiano voglia di fare una cosa di
questo tipo
ho portato a casa addirittura un
totalmente inatteso quarto posto che era
comunque il massimo che avrei potuto
ottenere con la preparazione che abbiamo
al momento una felicità incredibile ma
la cosa bella è che sono stato io a
scegliere di essere quel personality
sono stato via scendere anche di essere
questa persona qui perché io ho
utilizzato sia la bicicletta che la gara
come mezzo per riuscire a capire
determinate cose che sono stati
veramente importanti fondamentali e la
mia vita ci sono arrivato a 40 anni ma
ci sono arrivato ho capito che sono
stato io il responsabile al cento per
cento di ogni singolo successo e di ogni
singolo soddisfazione che ho ottenuto
nella mia vita come ho dovuto accettare
anche amaramente in certi momenti perché
dura da accettare però è la realtà sono
stato io il responsabile al cento per
cento di ogni insuccesso o
insoddisfazione e ogni cosa negativa che
mi è capitata nella mia vita perché di
dare come pat attori esterni da riporta
ad altre persone per riuscire a
giustificare un nostro fallimento è solo
un alibi ed è l'anima di non voler
essere veramente quello che
dobbiamo essere questa esperienza e ha
portato questi sfida fine l'ha portato
ad aprire delle porte nuove
totalmente questo comi ci sta che mi
aspetto delle strade totalmente nuovo e
che per me non so in questo momento sono
totalmente sconosciute ma sto vedendo
che sta succedendo di tutto di più al
momento bellissimo magari fra un anno ad
un bivio trovo un'altra aspirazione
tornerò alta ed ex rovigo fra cinque
anni racconta perché sono stato sulla
loro ci sarà solo so ora prima di
salutarvi che poi dopo quindi salutero
anche dopo la visione c'è quello che
doveva essere il trailer del tuo film mi
è venuto in mente di fare questo docu
film poi in realtà il l'evolversi delle
cose ha fatto cambiare un po tutto ma
ero sereno ero sereno perché accettavo
tutto quello che
succedere trasformato poi virtuale per
le pornostar che perché il problema non
esiste esiste ma quando non lo so non lo
so considera tale e soprattutto il
problema avete un problema a seconda
anche di come lo vuoi affrontare da
questo docu film è in realtà ne è venuta
fuori una serie tv che andrà in onda su
sky sport per dieci puntate e che grande
orgoglio
buona visione
[Applauso]
e na li inseguirà costorio ovunque vada
macina chilometri di strada
lei volontà tura bicicletta
in fretta
e ovunque vada
macina chilometri di strada ai volontà
tu la bicicletta in fretta
in fretta sei libero
lo sceglie la corona che attraverso una
catena condiziona il moto del sistema
monarchia meccanica che ha giurato fede
derna alle leggi della fisica statica
terminale quasi democratica se quando si
ferma si barrica libero o tirannica con
la fissa dello scatto senza freni che
difendono dall'impatto e manzoni del
pignone fare la rivoluzione portare il
movimento in ogni direzione incostanti
acrobazia si arrabbia l'energia dal
centro fino alla ferite degli altri è
solo una questione di rapporto tra
ingranaggi è tutto dire liscio fino a
che non ti scoraggi che l'unico motore
v6 turbo ii il fiatone
a spingere in salita per la vita il
carrozzone
la insegui la costorio completata la
macina chilometri di strada e volontà
bicicletta
in seguito costorio ovunque vada
macina chilometri di strada hai voluto
la bicicletta
in fretta
[Musica]
devo finire
ed è vero per quando faccio la storia di
instagram tenetevelo bene questo
applauso
l'unico limite a quanto in alto si può
salire 4 quanto ci chiediamo noi
io mi sono dimostrato che sia 40 anni si
può diventare anche un ciclista e di un
atleta ma io sono veramente convinto che
possiamo diventare che cosa vogliamo e
quello che vogliamo
in ogni istante della nostra vita perché
non è mai troppo tardi come dice il
detto mai dire mai dire che ormai rare
[Applauso]